[Música]
bueno los saludos porque saludar es
importante en filosofía para niños
saludar es el primer reconocimiento que
tenemos hacia el otro y yo quiero
preguntarles si saben con quién están
sentado en el día de hoy
si voltean a ver los derecha izquierda
reconocen a las personas que tienen
junto a ustedes
sabe quiénes son
saben quiénes son ustedes mismos
[Música]
saben ustedes cómo les gustaría vivir
saben ustedes en qué clase de mundo les
gustaría vivir
cuando salen a la calle les gustan las
personas con las que conviven
se sienten cómodos al manejar la calle
se sienten seguros cuando salen en la
noche a pasear
bueno estas y muchas más son algunas
preguntas que nos hacemos en la vida y
todo tiene que ver con la filosofía todo
tiene que ver con el mundo todo tiene
que ver con la forma en la que pensamos
cómo debemos de vivir todo tiene que ver
con el corazón y con el cerebro porque
buscamos en filosofía para niños está
justamente esta conexión pues voy a
platicarles algo interesante para mí no
sé si para ustedes pero ya ya intentaré
hacerlo ha sido interesante para mí
hacer filosofía para niños porque es un
programa educativo pero no es una clase
educativa levante la mano quien ha
tomado clases de filosofía solamente
ninguno lo recetaron desde secundaria
hasta preparatoria la materia si tenía
suerte te tocaba un buen maestro un buen
maestro que te ayudará a conocer qué han
pensado los filósofos y que debes de
hacer a través de la ética y hay alguna
materia interesantísima como la lógica
que nos enseñaban ciertos silogismos
para saber pensar alguien tomó estas
materias
todos tuvieron un buen maestro
afortunadamente los filósofos somos
autodidactas y tendremos tendemos a
hacer algunas estrategias para hacer de
algo aparentemente no tan entretenido
algo más entretenido pero eso no es
filosofía para niños filosofía para
niños es un programa educativo que tiene
método paso pero que busca hacer esto
es un proyecto de construcción social
que trabaja en las escuelas y se aplica
principalmente de los 2 a los 18 años
cuando yo venía para acá me toca con una
persona que supongo que está sentada
aquí y me decía que vas a presentar yo
filosofía para niños yo tengo un año muy
chiquita de 4 años todavía no le va a
tocar la idea es que le toque desde los
2 años que desde los 2 años pueda
explorar las ideas sobre el mundo que
nos toca vivir porque ya lo está
viviendo ya lo está experimentando y
sobre todo ya lo está pensando
reflexionando y cuestionando sé dónde yo
le digo a los niños te gusta el mundo
cómo están te gustaría hacer algo en el
mundo te gustaría mejorar el mundo
los niños protestan cosas maravillosas
como a mí le gustaría decir pintar el
mundo de colores
yo quisiera salir a cualquier hora a
pasear en la calle yo quisiera que los
adultos me regañaron tanto y los niños
están pensando y explorando el mundo que
les toca vivir cuando vean esa imagen
cuando a través de alguien que está
pensando y reflexionando solemos tener
esta persona una persona seria duda en
la mano en la cabeza pensando y pensando
pero está estática pero cuando yo voy a
las aulas y veo a los niños pensando de
esto
él se cuestiona sobre el mundo pero más
traigo esta imagen para platicarles lo
que él estaba pensando estábamos
hablando en clases sobre la importancia
de la responsabilidad de la autoridad
que tienen las personas sobre el mundo
etcétera y él empezó a decir la verdad
es que yo tengo un problema con algo que
me están diciendo los adultos un es el
problema que están diciendo los adultos
se han tasado diciéndome cuando seas
grande vas a mejorar el mundo ya que tú
estés en 11 donde vamos a ayudar a que
la gente sea mejor persona y decía yo yo
tengo que resolver el mundo que me están
dejando es el mundo que la verdad es que
manolo entiende más que la la red
bueno el niño sana el conflicto y es un
conflicto natural en filosofía para
niños trabajamos a partir de la realidad
de la experiencia de lo que sucede en su
mundo y aclaro dos cosas en dos mundos
en ya en el mundo presencial que estamos
teniendo todos y en el mundo hiper real
cuando aterricé en el avión ayer en
tierra
pero aterrizamos y en las traiciones de
vuelo para la gente félix la picaba se
dormía comunidad cuando el avión
aterriza que fue lo primero que hizo la
gente
inmediatamente desconectarse del mundo y
permear prender celulares mandar
mensajes del diable a conectarse con
otra realidad ese es el mundo que
nuestros niños están viviendo y cuando
digo niños también digo jóvenes y
efectivamente adultos porque los adultos
somos los que estamos educando a
nuestros niños y en nuestros jóvenes
quiero que vean esta imagen
junto a estos niños y les dije me puedes
explicar que es filosofía para niños y
se fusionan en una pared verde que
estaba por ahí hicieron esta imagen
esta imagen representa filosofía para
niños por tres cosas fundamentalmente
están viendo la foto si le están viendo
los ojos de los niños
bueno decían ellos quiero ver a la
cámara porque en filosofía para niños
trabaja el pensamiento crítico el que
observa a la realidad el que observa a
las personas y ayuda a analizar lo que
está sucediendo después se pusieron de
una forma creativa el pensamiento
creativo de filosofía para niños busca
si apreciar lo hermoso y lo bello de
este mundo pero también busca explorar
las alternativas para solucionar
aquellas cosas inciertas no esperabas
sorpresivas qué pretende
incluir la vida de los niños o sea el
mundo es una cosa inesperada
aparentemente entran a las 7 de la
mañana pero suceden muchas cosas en las
7 de la mañana que no les permite
necesariamente llegar y cumplir la norma
establecida y los niños a través de su
pensamiento creativo no pueden ir
resolviendo hay otro pensamiento
que se llevan bien los niños en esta
foto
bueno no puedo saber exactamente pero al
menos no se están peleando en esta foto
en esta foto está tratando de
representar el pensamiento cuidadoso el
pensamiento cuidadoso es aquel que te va
a permitir estar bien con una persona en
cualquier lugar en cualquier horario del
mundo en cualquier circunstancia en el
aula fuera del aula en el recreo cuando
estés con tus papás y el pensamiento
cuidador se tiene que ver con pienso en
ti
pero ayuda que necesitas entonces son un
pensamiento crítico creativo cuidadoso
pero ello creo que me gusta agregar nada
de esto funciona si no colaboramos entre
nosotros sería nuestro cuarto tipo de
pensamiento el pensamiento colaborativo
las imágenes hablan mucho y esta es una
imagen de maestras haciendo filosofía
para niños filosofía para niños se
trabaja desde los 2 años hasta los 18
como ya les había mencionado sin embargo
funciona a través de la formación que
tengan las maestras las maestras tienen
que vivir qué es esto del problema de
filosofía para niños para poder vivirlo
con ellos
estas son un colegio aquí en tijuana
esta otra imagen es de un colegio en el
que colaboró desde hace más de 11 años
en el que se trabaja en filosofía para
niños pero con algo muy especial que
quiero compartir el día de hoy hoy su
programa al paso 1 nos sentábamos en
círculo levantamos la mano quiero pedir
la palabra escuchamos una historia
principalmente las historias que
escribieron ansar y mati brightman al
respecto de filosofía para niños
escuchamos una historia luego dialogamos
y vamos generando argumentos e ideas
preguntas para poder llegar a las
mejores soluciones posibles atención con
esto no siempre se llega a respuestas
exactas y correctas
vamos a ir construyendo para los niños
respuestas tentativas ante lo que vamos
viendo porque al día siguiente te das
cuenta de que eso que pensaste ya no
funcionó
por ejemplo plutón en un planeta en los
que estuvimos los dos desde el 70
hablando de las filiales alimenticia que
plutón era un planeta y era hace unos
años dijeron sorpresa en los planetas no
es su plan de 'toy de y además no tiene
superficie esos hallazgos los vamos a ir
descubriendo a lo largo de la vida y los
niños debemos estar
'debemos me incluyo preparados para
enfrentarlo
proyecto de vida más que una clase una
metodología seguramente han escuchado
esta raza juntos es más todo tiene que
ver así es cómo operar el programa de
filosofía para niños de manera que
cuando se trabaja filosofía para niños
ya sea en méxico o en diferentes puntos
de este planeta se ve se siente la
posibilidad
se ve y se siente la posibilidad de
vivir el programa juntos y es mejor
estar juntos que que separamos
en esta imagen
como una alberca esta imagen pretende
explicarles a ustedes lo que es
filosofía para niños a veces estamos
hundidos a veces estamos en la
superficie pero estemos unidos con la
superficie eso es la realidad eso es la
vida para poder explorar
no siempre estamos juntos no siempre
estamos atentos
y quiero cerrar con cinco ideas
fundamentales pensar en los demás en el
bien común
podemos dialogar entre todos y dialogar
con niños
tenemos que tener algo que yo llamado
escucha activa si yo fuera ahorita a
preguntarle saliendo de aquí que dijo el
slip se acordarían
solamente se acordarían aquellos que
estuvieron atentos escuchando a lo que
dice la persona atentos a lo que el
corazón quiere compartir la escucha
activa es aquello que nos va a permitir
educar en este mundo de incertidumbres
mi propuesta es tratar de trabajar más
en conjunto colaborativamente como les
decía trabajaban derrumbando este
trabajo que muchas veces tenemos en
islas para construir continentes
les voy a contar una historia porque
filosofía para niños se trabajan con
historias
estuve hablando con ellos sobre el
cumpleaños todos han tenido alguna vez
sólo siete años
de los niños en esta fiesta en esta
reflexión de la clase de filosofía para
niños estaban explorando la idea de que
es un cumpleaños cuando se cumple años
un pequeño levantó la mano este es un
cumpleaños es aquella ocasión en la que
te parten un pastel hay juegos hay
diferentes actividades se cantan las
mañanitas y los niños empiezan a decir
pero qué pasaría si no hubiera pastel si
no me cantarán las mañanitas y si no
hubiera regalos muchos empezaron a decir
no pasa nada tú tranquilo a veces los
papás pueden o no pueden hacer
yo me di cuenta y lo que usted se dio
cuenta en ese momento es que esos niños
no estaban pensando por sí mismos esos
niños no estaban aflorando este
pensamiento auténtico que nos permite
reconocer y explorar las ideas del mundo
entonces yo solamente les dije así pues
la verdad es que a mí si no me lleva un
pastel me siento triste si no me cantan
las mañanitas para que nos juntamos
todos la verdad es que cuál es el
objetivo entonces empezaban a decir yo
también si mejor si quiero fiesta quiero
hacer quiero y empezaron a decir sus
ideas y sus argumentos para explorar
este mundo incierto que nos está rodeado
pero una niña levantó la mano ahorita me
van a tratar de adivinar ustedes cuántos
años tenían estos niños levanta la mano
y dijo pero un desliz
aunque no haya pastel aunque no haya
fiesta inclusive aunque no puedan estar
mis papás ese día nosotros si seguimos
cumpliendo años
ese día empezó a pensar empezó a
acelerar argumentos a partir de algo que
en filosofía para niños es fundamental a
partir del pensamiento en comunidad de
diálogo claro que lo convencional no lo
que queremos nuestra fiesta aparte de
los fuegos los regalitos cuántos niños
cuántos niños creen que tenían estos
niños
cuatro años
más o menos segundo de preescolar era
cuando estaban explorando esas esas
ideas otros niños explorando el
pensamiento auténtico estaban hablando
de los miedos y los miedos es un tema
importante para filosofía para niños
todo si el miedo no y un niño marco
levantar la mano y dice los miedos
hay que decir que no a los miedos y qué
pasa cuando nos van a vacunar entonces
cuando nos da una vacuna tenemos que
decir que sí aunque nos dé miedo por
nuestro bien pues esto es filosofía para
niños filosofía para niños es compartir
el corazón la vida y el mundo y por eso
traje está linda pelotita
quiero que lo reciban y traten de
pasarla en todos y cada uno de ustedes
porque filosofía para niños es
finalmente compartir el mundo que
tenemos y les agradezco mucho me
escuchan
[Aplausos]
[Música]